[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele menschen auf der ganzen welt sehen
deutschland als ein land der extreme
der positive wieder negative extreme und
sie sind von diesen extremen zumeist auf
die ein oder andere art fasziniert
[Musik]
nazi-deutschland zum beispiel ist noch
immer die ikone des ultimativen lösen
lahnstein fkk und autobahnen ohne
tempolimit sind auch welt bekannt aber
doch wesentlich positiver besetzt das
größte positiven aber mit welchen
deutschland die welt wohl nachhaltig am
stärksten beeindruckt ist seine
scheinbar unbezwingbare wirtschaftskraft
selbst wenn ist völlig zerstört am boden
lag stieg ist binnen kurzer zeit wieder
wie durch ein wunder bis an die
weltspitze
nicht umsonst sprach man oft von einem
wirtschaftswunder und auch heute ist
deutschland noch die fabrik der welt gut
jetzt werden einige von euch vielleicht
sagen aber mag du bist wohl nicht ganz
up to date china ist doch die fabrik der
welt aus ostasien kommt die ganzen
fernseher handys computer und fast alles
was der ständig tauchen und ja so ein
teil hat er damit recht china führt das
weltweite export ranking an aber das ist
nicht die ganze wahrheit denn um all
diese produkte herzustellen müssen die
chinesen eine menge aus dem ausland
importieren deutschland hingegen
verkauft viel mehr ins ausland als es
dort einkauft
im jahr 2019 bedruckte außenhandels
profis deutschlands ganze 293 milliarden
dollar
um diesen sogenannten
leistungsbilanzüberschuss wurde
deutschland gegenüber anderen ländern in
nur einem einzigen jahr reicher das
profit betrug nur 183 milliarden das ist
grob kopf nur 1 27 ssten dessen was die
deutschen im welthandel verdient haben
pro kopf ist deutschland den ich sowieso
der absolut unangefochten
exportweltmeister nur mal zum vergleich
deutschland exportierte im jahr 2009 10
waren im wert von über 1 5 millionen
dollar in alle welt die zweitplatzierten
usa mit einer vier mal zu großen
bevölkerung kam praktisch auf denselben
wert 1,6 billionen und china mit einer
17 mal so großen einwohnerzahl
exportiert nur anderthalb mal so viel
wie das im vergleich dazu winzige
deutschland nämlich 2,5 millionen
tatsächlich wird jedes zehnte produkt
das auf dem internationalen markt
verkauft wird ein gut ort termin
hergestellt um welche waren geht es aber
klar wir alle kennen große marken wie
bmw mercedes audi und vw
aber das ist nur die spitze des eisbergs
so ist zum beispiel euer handy ja ich
weiß da steht es wird in china drauf
aber was heißt das wo kommen die ganzen
einzelteile her die da in china erwartet
wurden und wo kommen die maschinen harry
diese einzelteile zusammen bauen nun in
ganz vielen fällen wird dies deutschland
seien zum beispiel wird der kleine
lagesensor der eurem handy screen dreht
höchstwahrscheinlich von bosch sensor
tec hergestellt und auch die meisten für
den herstellungsprozess eures handys
essentiellen maschinen sind wohl die
früchte deutscher ingenieurskunst
mit anderen worten deutschland stellt
all die dinge her welche für die
herstellung der endprodukte
unverzichtbar sind so weit so gut
deutschland ist top exporteure wieso
aber eigentlich lohnt es sich doch eher
dass fabriken anordnung mit niedrigen
lohnkosten gebaut werden oder wie konnte
also ausgerechnet deutschland mit seinen
relativ hohen kosten und teurem
sozialstaat zu einem derartigen
industrie kraftpaket werden und diese
stellung bis heute halt heute werden wir
diese frage natürlich beantworten und
die ema wird uns dabei ein blick zurück
in die geschichte helfen wenn es nämlich
um die frage geht warum nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg gerade westdeutschland wieder
so schnell wirtschaftlich zu fassen uns
dann den anderen großen europäischen
nationen davon allen konnte und ich bin
mir sicher dass euch einige dinge dieser
geschichte selbst dann überraschen
werden fasst ihr euch schon gut in der
deutschen geschichte auskennt
[Musik]
der liberalismus nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg lag europa in trümmern
der gemeinsame feind der alliierten nazi
deutschland war besiegt worden und stand
nun unter militär besatzung der
siegermächte westdeutschland war durch
die usa großbritannien und frankreich
gesetzt aus deutschland durch die soffin
doch damit kam auf europa schon wieder
die nächste bedrohung von freiheit und
frieden zu der sowjetische diktator
stalin war unberechenbar geworden und
wollte seine macht über ganz europa
ausdehnen dazu forderte er in ganz
europa kommunistische kräfte welche die
demokratischen regierungen im westen
stürzen soll die usa und großbritannien
hatten große angst davor dass die
menschen durch not und hunger in die
arme von radikalen getrieben würden
kommunisten aber irgendwann auch wieder
nazis schließlich wollte man aus den
fehlern des dass seine vertrags wären in
diesen bildeten die sieger des ersten
weltkriegs den verliere deutschland
schwere strafen und reparationszahlungen
auf wo es wirtschaftlich am boden zu
halten
diese würde sollte der neu geschaffenen
ersten demokratie der deutschen der
sogenannten weimarer republik
schließlich das genick brechen
denner dass dadurch am boden liegende
deutsche volk wandte sich radikalen
kräften zu welche die demokratischen
kräfte bis aufs blut bekämpfen und
schließlich die nazis an die macht
brachten dies sollte sich nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht wiederholen
weder in deutschland noch in irgendeinem
anderen land westeuropas
die usa wollten westeuropa stabilisieren
beim ein stalin unter kommunismus dort
keine chance haben würden und
deutschland wollten sie aus einer vorher
die stabilität europas mit pferden macht
zu einem starken stabilisator europas
machen wie aber sollte man sich an
stellen nun die usa legten einen
gewaltigen hilfsplan auf den sogenannten
arche plan
dieser plan war so gestaltet dass alle
vom krieg betroffenen ländern europas
gelder zum wiederaufbau bekamen auch
jene von der sowjetunion besetzt ist
aline verbots diesen jedoch die annahme
der hilfsgelder strikt dies lag auch
daran dass eine bedingung zur auszahlung
das mittel war dass die regierungen in
den medien bekannt machen mussten dass
die usa ihnen helfen diese werbung für
den klassenfeind wollte stalin natürlich
nicht zulassen und so wurden die länder
im osten auf ostdeutschland schon mal
stark benachteiligt denn anstatt ihnen
hilfen zu schicken tat die sowjetunion
das genaue gegenteil
sie forderte reparationen demontierte
moderne industrieanlagen und schickte
sie quasi als beute nach russland ganz
anders die amerikaner
sie erlaubten der deutschen wirtschaft
zu viel zu produzieren wie sie wollte
aber statt panzern pumpen und nachwuchs
sollte sie nun ganz westeuropa mit
qualitativ hochwertigen strukturen
eisenbahnen und industriemaschinen
versorgen die idee dahinter war dass der
rest westeuropas dann die hochwertigen
deutschen waren kaufen und damit seine
eigene infrastruktur auf vordermann
bringen sollte so dass ein stabiles
wirtschaftliches abhängigkeitsverhältnis
und netzwerks zwischen diesen starken
und steht und hat dieser ambitionierte
plan der amerikaner funktioniert ja klar
und sie denn aus dieser idee entstanden
die europäische wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
und schließlich die europäische union
der westteil deutschlands geriet somit
von der rolle eines landes das
schrecklichste verbrechen begangen hatte
und dafür bestraft werden sollte in die
rolle eines partners denen man vor allem
dabei heißt wieder auf die beine zu
kommen und der einen dann im kampf gegen
den gemeinsamen feind den kommunismus
unterstützen soll
hilfen aus dem marshall-plan flossen
jedoch in alle länder westeuropas
jetzt kommt aber der große unterschied
zwischen westdeutschland und den anderen
empfänger der hilfsgelder wie frankreich
großbritannien oder italien
denn obwohl deutschland nur einen
relativ kleinen anteil bekam weste es
diesen am effektivsten ein und zwar mit
einer strategie die sich am ende als
besonders schlau herausstellen sollte
und bis heute ein riesenunterschied
zwischen deutschland und seinen
europäischen nachbarn aus macht
insgesamt flossen im rahmen des
marshall-plans hilfen im wert von 13
milliarden dollar nach europa heute
wären dies etwa 130 milliarden aber
jetzt haltet euch fest westdeutschland
bekannter von nur elf prozent den
größten batzen und 26 prozent trifft
sich das vereinigte königreich ab und
frankreich 18 prozent trotzdem schaffte
es deutschland aus seinem geld das
meiste zu machen während in ländern wie
frankreich die hilfsgelder nämlich zum
großteil dafür verwendet wurden um waren
aus den usa für die notleidende
bevölkerung einzukaufen schulen zu
begleichen die währung zu stabilisieren
oder verschiedene nicht industrielle
projekte zu fördern hatte die
westdeutsche regierung eine andere idee
einer wie sich herausstellen sollte
brilliante idee
und die ging sie mit dem geld aus der
masse an hilfe gründet deutschland erst
mal eine bank wow jetzt werden natürlich
einige sagen da wollten sich wohl ein
paar raffgierige banker von der hilfe
fette bowling abzweigen nicht wahr
aber so war das nicht diese bank sollte
keine gewöhnliche bank sein sondern eine
staatseigene förderbank die
kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau kurz kfw
wurde zu einer schlüssel institutionen
des deutschen wirtschaftswunders und hat
bis heute eine einzigartige bedeutung
für den wohlstand aller deutschen ihre
aufgabe ist es mit besonders günstigen
krediten all jene projekte zu fördern
welche der staat als wichtig zur
weiteren entwicklung von wirtschaft und
wohlstand erachtet dies können zb
existenzgründer sein
häuslbauer oder öffentliche
infrastrukturprojekte was aber ist nun
der hauptunterschied zwischen dem
deutschen modell welches förderung durch
günstige kredite betreibt und den der
anderen länder welche die hilfsgelder
einfach als zum nationen verschenken nun
während die subventionen nur einmal
ausgezahlt werden können und dann
wechselt müssen die kredite irgendwann
wenn sich das projekt findet hat an die
kfw wieder zurückgezahlt werden diese
kann dann damit immer wieder neue
projekte fördern
dadurch werden die hilfsgelder aus dem
marshall-plan in deutschland bis heute
recycelt heute ist die kfw die weltweit
größte staatliche förderbank sowie die
nach bilanzsumme die drittgrößte bank
deutschlands
in frankreich hingegen lief vieles ganz
anders zum einen wurde das geld sofort
verbraucht doch damit würden die
unterschiede noch nicht auf der
französische präsident general de gaulle
war ein militär- und kein großer freund
von privatunternehmen sein politisches
credo der sogenannte der regisseur war
die verstaatlichung von großunternehmen
und eine zentralistische führung der
gesamten wirtschaft des landes nach dem
vorbild einer armee in westdeutschland
hingegen verbrachten sowohl
bundeskanzler konrad adenauer als auch
sein finanzminister ludwig erhard viele
jahre damit über ihr eigenes
wirtschaftssystemen nachzudenken
heraus kam eine mischung aus einer
wettbewerbsorientierten freien
marktwirtschaft und einem von der
regierung bereitgestellten sich reißen
für dieses system suchten sich die
experten damals den schrecklichsten name
aus der ihn einfallen konnte
ordoliberalismus aber keine angst es
gibt auch einen viel schöneren dafür die
soziale marktwirtschaft da wird einem
ganz warm ums herz nicht trauen
wettbewerb ist das vielversprechendste
mittel um wohlstand zu erreichen und zu
sichern
ludwig erhard
mit anderen worten während sowohl die
wirtschaft ganz frankreichs zentral von
paris aus lenken wollte entwarf konrad
adenauer 1 system bei denen die
bundesregierung eine reihe von
bedingungen aufstellt alle anderen
akteure die unternehmen und
gewerkschaften haben ihre eigenen
entscheidungen treffen das alles war
aber nicht purer zufall denn der wunsch
nach einem hohen maß an
dezentralisierung und föderalismus in
der jungen bundesrepublik sprang der
föderalen tradition deutschlands und vor
allem der forderung der alliierten
siegermächte deutschlands neuer stars
verordnung müsste so gut wie nur möglich
eine konzentration der macht verhindern
denn diese hatte in der vergangenheit
eher zu deren missbrauch und
gleichschaltung durch die nazis geführt
und wie bereits erwähnt sollte als
weiterer schutz vor allem abgleiten
deutschland in politische extreme die
westdeutsche wirtschaft in ein eng
gestricktes netzwerk mit seinen
europäischen nachbarn eingebunden werden
damit europa jedoch in deutschland
einkaufen konnte braucht es auch eine
stabile währung die alte reichsmark war
jedoch nichts anderes als ein wertloser
papierwerk da die nazis ihre größten
dingen pläne nicht nur mit raub gold
finanzierten sondern auch indem sie geld
drucken wie folgt seit 1946 verhandelten
daher die alliierten auch die udssr
miteinander um eine neue währung für
ganz deutschland einzuführen dies auch
jetzt kam aber immer wieder mit allen
möglichen neuen bedingungen welche die
westalliierten nicht bereit waren zu
akzeptieren die einführung einer neuen
währung zog sich über mehrere jahre hin
die menschen litten große not im
industrie landwirtschaft und handel
hatten kein interesse daran ihre guten
waren gegen wertlose reichsmark zu
tauschen
lebensmittel wurden streng rationiert
und konnten nicht einfach frei erworben
werden sondern nur mit
lebensmittelmarken und welchen jede
person nur eine begrenzte zahl zugeteilt
bekamen
ende 1946 wurde dabei jeden erwachsenen
lediglich eine tagesration von 1550
kilokalorien zugestanden
tja das klingt nicht gerade nach
wirtschaftswunder wie also hat es
deutschland trotzdem geschafft sich aus
dieser misere und hunger wirtschaft zu
befreien
eine stabile d mark nach langem hin und
her und qualvollen jahren sendung
entschieden sich die amerikaner dazu
sich nicht mehr auf die sowjets zu
verlassen
sie führten daher losen 148 in der red
zone im hauruck-verfahren die demat ein
plötzlich quasi über nacht waren die
schaufenster und geschäfte die der
voller waren und sogar jeder menge an
luxusgütern
doch woher kam plötzlich diese ganzen
produkte und die deutsche wirtschaft
doch im krieg zerstört worden war
nun zum einen hatte die deutsche
wirtschaft schon vorher kräftig auch
lager vorproduziert wollte aber die
guten produkte nicht für wertlose
reichsmark verkaufen
viel wichtiger weiter eine andere nur
wenig bekannte tatsache und jetzt haltet
euch fest denn wir werden in diesem
augenblick einen weitverbreiteten mythos
zertrümmern es handelt sich um die
legende vom völlig zerstörten
deutschland das im krieg alles verloren
hatte einer trümmerwüste in der alles
neu aufgebaut werden musste und zwar von
trümmerfrauen denn die männer waren ja
alle im krieg gefallen nun diese legende
gehört zum größten teil ins land der
märchen denn allein die
industriebetriebe westdeutschland
produzierten 1949 also nur ein jahr nach
der währungsreform bereits so viel wie
im jahre 1936 die industrie des ganzen
deutschen reiches aber wie soll das denn
möglich gewesen sein wenn alles zerstört
und die meisten tot waren
so eine riesige industrie konnte doch
nicht in vier jahren durch trümmerfrauen
aus dem boden gestampft worden seien
wurde sie auch nicht die wahrheit ist
eine ganz andere
denn deutschlands industrie wurde im
krieg tatsächlich nur wenig beschädigt
zudem hatten die nazis sehr viel in die
industrieproduktion investiert die
produktionsanlagen waren 1945 um 20
prozent höher als 1936 also vor dem
krieg noch im jahr 1944 also im letzten
kriegsjahr als deutsche städte fast
täglich bombardiert wurde befand sich
die deutsche industrie noch immer an der
spitze des weltstandard die
industrieproduktion stürzte erst gegen
ende 1944 ab aber nicht weil die
maschinen und andere produktions an
zerstört worden waren sondern weil die
transportinfrastruktur zusammenbrach es
konnten also keine rohstoffe angeliefert
werden denn die alliierten bomber hat
man vor allem wohngebiete straßen und
eisenbahnlinien zerstört nicht jedoch
die produktionsanlagen da wird
die wirtschaft stand also bereits sofort
wieder volle kanne zu produzieren so
bald in rohstoffe zur verfügung standen
denn energie und rohstoffe für die
industrie in stein kohle und stahl gab
es genug denn auch der bergbau war vom
krieg kaum betroffen und die vorräte
stapelten sich seit ende 1944
deutschlands industrie war also zu
kriegsende noch immer absolute
weltspitze
die maschinen waren noch alle da und
fast alle unbeschädigt man brauchte
jetzt nur zwei dinge um den betrieb
wieder voll aufnehmen zu können
transport infrastruktur und
arbeitskräfte die transportinfrastruktur
konnte relativ schnell wieder
hergestellt werden und was war mit den
arbeitskräften gab es wegen der vielen
gefallenen soldaten nicht einen riesigen
mangel ganz und gar nicht eine
westdeutschland profitierte von einem
gewaltigen sondereffekt nach dem krieg
kam ein riesiger strom von
deutschsprachigen und hochgradig
qualifizierten flüchtlingen und
vertriebenen
zunächst kamen rund zehn millionen
vertriebenen aus dem osten und südosten
europas und später noch drei millionen
flüchtlinge aus der ddr das war eine
gewaltige workflows und die unternehmen
konnten so bei den arbeitskräften aus
dem vollen schöpfen und auch die
lohnkosten blieben dadurch erträglich
niedrig wie ihr seht was ich da
voraussetzung für die westdeutsche
wirtschaft nach dem krieg also viel
besser als viele glauben
was fehlte war eben nur eine stabile
währung damit die menschen und die
wirtschaft von der leine gelassen werden
denn nur mit einer geeigneten währung
als schmierstoff konnte die wirtschaft
ihr volles potenzial entfalten und jede
menge wohlstand für die menschen
generieren jetzt kommt aber eigentlich
wieder eine überraschung denn in
deutschland ist bei seiner
währungspolitik auch ziemlich
unkonventionell und anders als eine
nachbarin vorgegangen und das hat sich
als voller erfolg erwiesen was genau
meine ich damit nun lasst mich etwas
ausholen
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ihr
schon mal davon gehört habt dass die
abwertung einer währung die exporte
eines landes ankommt oder denn durch die
abwertung einer währung gegenüber dem
ausland kann man seine waren dort
billiger anbieten und ist damit
konkurrenzfähiger zumindest was den
preis angelangt das ist die theorie die
von den meisten ökonomen und regierungen
heutzutage vertreten wird und trotzdem
hat westdeutschland damals genau das
gegenteil getan
in der zweiten hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts wurde die deutsche markt zu
einer der stabilsten währungen der welt
und jetzt wagt du dich vielleicht dies
ist möglich dass deutschland so viel
exportieren konnte wenn sie ihre
produkte nicht zu billig herstellen
konnten die andere auf den weltmarkt nun
lasst uns zur beantwortung dieser frage
doch direkt in die geschichte einer
echten firma eintauchen einer firma und
er wahrscheinlich noch nie etwas gehört
habt und die gerade deswegen so typisch
ist für die erfolgsgeschichte der
deutschen wirtschaft dies ist die
geschichte der usa marschieren gmbh mit
heute rund 220 beschäftigten diese firma
wurde direkt nach dem krieg im jahr 1996
gegründet und spezialisierte sich auf
die fertigung von maschinen für die
herstellung von schuhen zunächst wusste
dass man dafür viele maschinen und teile
aus die usa importieren
doch dank einer stabilen währung war der
preis für den import dieser maschinen
relativ niedrig sie mussten auch ein
fabrikgebäude mieten und da die
inflation oder tief niedrig war konnten
sie damit rechnen dass die miete nicht
stark schwanken oder steigen würde und
sie ihre kosten auch bis ins nächste
jahr gut vorhersehen können aber nicht
nur das da deutsche unternehmen nicht
durch niedrigere
preise konkurrieren konnten blieb auch
diesmal nichts anderes übrig als bei den
kunden mit innovationen zu punkten im
jahr 1960 investierten sie in modernster
technologie zur herstellung von munition
und zehn jahre später war das war
weltweit führend bei maschinen zur
herstellung von pvc suhl
ich bin sicher dass auch duschen trägst
der sohle mit einer dessen maschine
hergestellt wurde denn dieses
unternehmen mit nur 220 mitarbeitern
verkauft seine maschinen in jedes land
in dem schuhe massenweise hergestellt
werden die zum beispiel hier aber
diesmal ist nur ein typisches beispiel
für die tausenden und abertausenden von
kleinen und mittleren unternehmen den
sogenannten mittelstand der deutschland
reich gemacht hat und ja ich weiß was du
hast ein wenn du wirst im jahr 2002
gaben die deutschen doch ihre harte
d-mark auf und führten den euro ein
saßen nun also mit ihren weichwährung
machbaren die italien und spanien in
einem boot aber denk mal kurz nach zu
jedem zeitpunkt hatten sich die
wirtschaftsstruktur dieser länder
bereits gemäß der jeweiligen
währungspolitik in der vergangenheit
ausgeformt deutsche unternehmen waren im
jahr 2002 bereits wettbewerbsfähige als
alle anderen da sie eine kultur der
innovation statt der billigproduktion
entwickelt hatten aber es gibt noch ein
paar andere gründe dafür warum sich
gerade in deutschland ein so
erfolgreiches modell für innovative
unternehmen etablieren konnte und diese
faktoren sind wohl ebenso wichtig wie
die vorgenannten
das bildungssystem ich weiß ganz genau
was ihr denkt kommt schon mag
deutschland gilt doch nicht gerade als
weltweiter spitzenreiter in sachen
bildungssystem in der pisa-studie
schafft es deutschland noch nicht mal
auf platz 16
man muss aber bedenken welche
fähigkeiten bei pisa gemessen werden
machte lesen und naturwissenschaften
diese kompetenzen sind unbestritten alle
sehr wichtig aber noch lange nicht alles
was man drauf haben muss um später im
beruf erfolgreich zu sein denn was bei
pisa nicht getestet wird ist einer der
schlüsselfaktoren für den erfolg der
deutschen industrie praxisbezug das
heißt wie gut kommen die absolventen im
berufsalltag in den jeweiligen
unternehmen zurecht und in puncto
praxiskompetenz können die deutsche
schüler scheinbar allemal mithalten und
das ist das ergebnis einer weiteren
deutschen besonderheit des systems der
dualen ausbildung bei diesem geht der
schüler bzw auszubildenden nur die
hälfte der zeit wegen einer schule der
unter anderen hätte der zeit lernt und
arbeitet er bereits in einer firma und
bekommt sollte auch ein kleines gehalt
und ja dieses gehalt ist ziemlich
wichtig denn die tatsache dass ein
unternehmen in seine auszubildenden
investiert wird dazu dass es in dem
genau jene fertigkeiten vermittelt und
bringt mit denen es wiederum später geld
verdienen
anderenfalls würde das unternehmen ja
geld aus dem fenster werfen und so eher
werden viele deutsche schüler im
gegensatz zu ihren peers in anderen
ländern schon sehr früh die fähigkeit
sich in der realen arbeitswelt zu
bewegen
tatsächlich bleiben viele von ihnen in
dem unternehmen in dem sie ihre
ausbildung absolviert haben und diese
unternehmen erhalten dafür gut
ausgebildete arbeitskräfte genau solche
welches sie brauchen uns genau das zu
ihnen passen
wie heißt es so schön sitzt passt
wackelt und hat luft aber wenn wir schon
über arbeitskräfte sprechen lasst uns
noch über einen weiteren wichtigen punkt
des deutschen systems sprechen
gewerkschaften in anderen ländern wie
frankreich und spanien werden die
meisten arbeitsgesetz im parlament
verabschiedet in deutschland sieht das
aber ganz anders aus das zauberwort
lautet tarifautonomie
dies ist ein in der deutschen verfassung
verankerten grundsatz dass gehälter und
sonstige arbeitsbedingungen zwischen den
tarifpartnern das heißt gewerkschaften
auf der einen und arbeitgebern auf der
anderen seite ausgehandelt werden und
zwar frei von eingriffen des staates und
die tarifautonomie ist in deutschland
ein heiliges gut bis 2015 hatten die
deutschen nicht einmal einen staatlich
festgelegten mindestlohn denn ein
solches gesetz schränkt tja die
tarifautonomie das heißt die
verhandlungsfreiheit der tarifpartner 1
in deutschland sind gewerkschaften also
vereinigungen von arbeitnehmern
arbeitern angestellten und beamten von
sehr großer bedeutung
[Musik]
unternehmen und mehr als 2000
beschäftigten sind gesetzlich
verpflichtet
gewerkschaftsvertreter in ihre
aufsichtsräte aufzunehmen
dh die arbeitnehmervertreter sitzen
gleichberechtigt mit den vertretern der
aktionäre in den gremien welche die
chefs den vorstand des unternehmens nur
stimmen
so sitzen bei siemens beispielsweise 10
aktionärsvertreter im aufsichtsrat und
zehn arbeitnehmervertreter
das ist so gesetzlich vorgeschrieben
keine mehrheitsentscheidungen kann also
ohne die arbeitnehmervertreter gibt zu
zu werden aber welche praktischen
auswirkungen hat dies nun auf das
geschäft und die kultur dieser
unternehmen nun vergleichen wir diesmal
mit einem großen spanischen unternehmen
wie der telefonica diese hat keine
gewerkschaftsvertreter in ihrem
aufsichtsrat gesellschafter können sich
nur im betriebsrat organisieren und dort
themen wie gehälter oder
arbeitsbedingungen sprechen anders in
deutschland dort haben die
gewerkschaften bei jeder entscheidung
des unternehmens ein mitspracherecht
wenn siemens auf einen neuen markt tätig
werden oder ein neues produkt auf den
markt bringen will entscheiden die
aktionärs und arbeitnehmervertreter
gleichermaßen
und jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht ist
dies für das unternehmen denn ein
vorteil
normalerweise geht man doch davon aus
dass gewerkschaften der natürliche feind
eines unternehmens sind oder nun das
muss doch nicht sein denkt mal darüber
nach dank der mitwirkung der
arbeitnehmervertreter wissen die
mitarbeiter von siemens oder bmw viel
besser woran sie sind und wie ist nun
das unternehmen wirklich steht und wenn
sie sehen dass es schlecht läuft sind
sich viel eher bereit kompromisse
einzugehen denn sie wollen ja nicht an
dem ast sägen auf dem sie alle sitzen so
können sie sich beispielsweise er damit
abfinden ihre arbeitszeit zu kürzen
anstatt entlassen zu werden
[Musik]
opel kürzt arbeitszeit an deutschen
standorten
dies erklärt dann warum deutsche
unternehmen während der finanzkrise im
jahr 2008 keine massiven einschnitte
machen mussten und das ist gut für die
arbeitnehmer und gut für die unternehmen
welche dadurch krisen besser überstehen
können und danach schneller wieder auf
die beine kommen
jetzt werden natürlich ein paar von euch
misstrauische anwenden die
gewerkschaftsfunktionäre sind doch
bestimmt gruppe und arbeiten mit den
kapitalisten zusammen um die arbeiter
auszubeuten und selbst vergünstigungen
zu kassieren
so lief es auch bei volkswagen das seine
betriebsräte mit edel prostituierten
versorgt hat nun es ist wahr das ist
diese skandale gab aber man kann in
großen und ganzen sache ausgehen dass
das system trotzdem gut funktioniert
schließlich hat sich das deutsche modell
schon in viele krisen bewährt und auch
wenn es sie nun wieder lange
durststrecken gab hat sich deutschland
immer wieder wie ein stehaufmännchen
brabbelt und landete am ende immer
wieder an der weltspitze
jetzt seid ihr an der reihe glaubt ihr
dass wir die schlüsselfaktoren des
deutschen wirtschafts erfolgs richtig
identifiziert haben oder fallen euch
noch weitere wichtige umstände ein denkt
ihr dass andere länder davon lernen
können oder handelt es sich um den
spezifischen eigenarten dass die
woanders nur schwer umgesetzt werden
können bitte schreibt alles was euch das
ein feld in den kommentarbereich unter
diesem video
vergesst bitte nicht dass wir jede woche
neue videos hochladen werden also
verpasst keines unserer updates
abonniert unseren kanal und klickt auch
auf das symbol oben rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden
wir hoffen dass dieses video etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gibt uns einen
daumen hoch und unterstütze uns in den
tests mit deinen freunden
machs gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]